okay guys it is the 10th of March today
my name is Jess MacDonald and your
change into gamespot news today a game
is facing a ban for being too violent
which would usually be just another day
in gaming but it's a little weird when
the game in question is minecraft the
blocky pixelated universe of death as I
assume the authorities in this story see
it is heading to court in Turkey due to
its violent nature specifically Turkey's
family and social policies ministry have
said that depictions of violence in the
game are too much to overlook despite
its educational merit as they are
seeking to have it and the ministry's
report went on to say that because the
mob creatures must be killed to protect
play creation quote the game is based on
violence they also suspect that children
who play it could develop social
isolation due to the abuse and
harassment presence in wine crafts
online mode Microsoft have encouraged
those concerned about violence to play
on the peaceful setting or in the
creative mode which removes the creeps
as a result of this story I wanted to
find out what games you actually were
allowed to play in Turkey but it turns
out googling turkey games didn't provide
the results I was after GTA 5 online
Heights by now live across Xbox and
PlayStation consoles if you're at least
ranked 12 and earn a high-end apartment
in the game you can lead a heist while
everybody else is welcome to take pot
and play along Rockstar describes heists
as massive multi-layered four-player
cooperative missions just like payday
although they didn't add the payday part
you'll work together to take on five
total heists including an introductory
heist which you can play with two people
instead of four Rockstar have also
released the bevy of content we talked
about yesterday which includes adversary
modes as well as new weapons activities
and
finally information about the upcoming
Playstations war firmware update has
leaked and he's what you're gonna get
thanks to twitter user is a parrot who
found themselves in a firmware beta
testing group for the 2.50 update it
looks like the long-awaited suspend
resume feature is coming in the parrot
wrote suspend resume while watching
netflix the ps4 will pick up where
you're watching and not just reboot the
entire app it's really in memory the
user also confirmed that the update will
include more accessibility options black
text to speech and text sliders as well
as new backup data functionality
regarding the leak sony have said the
system updates will be out soon and
they'll have more info to share shortly
let me know down in the comments if you
think minecraft could be interpreted as
violent or not and why you can have to
gain spot or we've got news on the
oculus getting smellivision and the xbox
one latest update that is all the good
stuff that i have for you today be sure
let me know what you cared about down in
that comment section and I'll see you
same time